so listen this this next story gives me
no pleasure to tell you this but I do a
political show and when I have a
personal experience that's relevant to
the 2020 Democratic primary that is an
important topic on this program I have
to tell you about it it would be really
weird for me not to talk about this now
as many of you know I'm voting for
Bernie Sanders in the Massachusetts
primary on March 3rd I would vote for
any of the Democratic candidates over
Donald Trump and I will support the
eventual nominee good yeah good okay so
so far I've been canvassed by two
campaigns here in Massachusetts two
weeks ago a Bloomberg canvasser
volunteer came to my door and talked to
me about Michael Bloomberg and this week
the Bernie Sanders campaign came to my
door to Bernie Sanders they were
volunteers this was not paid staff came
to my door I didn't immediately tell
them who I was voting for and they very
quickly instead of talking up Bernie
about his policies they immediately
started attacking Elizabeth Warren to my
face and I think this is a terrible
strategy if I were Bernie Sanders I
wouldn't want my canvassers doing this
and by the way I'm sure Bernie doesn't I
mean clearly these were folks who were
not following you know Pat and Max told
told us on the bonus show last week that
they went up to New Hampshire to canvass
for Bernie ahead of the New Hampshire
primary and they had an app and the app
outlines how to handle different types
of objections and nowhere in there was
there anything about attacking other
candidates so to be very clear these
were obviously not individuals acting on
the direction from the Bernie Sanders
campaign but it should be made super
clear I think to everybody who is
volunteering to canvass for Bernie or
whoever do not badmouth other candidates
don't do it because it makes you look
bad and also don't do it because if the
primary thing in the end is to remove
Donald Trump we don't want to campaign
for our candidate in a way that could
potentially hurt the eventual nominee in
the future if it is to be someone else
and the people who came to my door to
the Bernie supporters to the Canvassers
we're saying things like we support
Bernie the
Elizabeth Warren doesn't really care
about working people like Bernie does
they said that on health care Elizabeth
Warren doesn't even care about giving
everyone health care right away and I
think the spontaneous attacks on Warren
are bad maybe here in Massachusetts were
seeing some of it because the last poll
we have is from October but at the time
Warren was the presumptive frontrunner
here although we haven't had a poll in
months and I don't know who's actually
winning and I I don't even think that
using the word
I don't think Warren wants to give
everyone healthcare I don't even think
that's the right language in my mind I
would be talking about Bernie wants to
ensure everybody receives the health
care they need which to me sounds better
than using this language of giving
everyone healthcare so again these were
volunteer Canvassers they are you know
based on what pat told us they get a 30
minute training of some kind before
going out there and doing their thing
clearly these were folks who I give them
the benefit of the doubt I assume they
have the best intentions they're
campaigning for the person they think is
best for the country and they're doing
it vigorously and they are trying to do
it in the way that they believe would be
most persuasive but persuasive but the
point is if Bernie is the nominee we
don't gain anything by going around and
attacking Elizabeth Warren to people
you've just met who you haven't even
revealed yet how they plan to vote
had I been a Warren supporter am I going
to be convinced to vote Bernie because
to canvassers showed up at my house and
trashed the person that maybe I'm
considering supporting I don't think so
I'm not gonna say you know I didn't
think about that about it that way
Warren doesn't care about working people
I'm gonna switch my vote to Bernie I'm
not blaming Bernie these aren't paid
campaign staff these were volunteers but
it's not good in general you don't want
to do canvassing where you show up and
attack other candidates either point out
objective policy hit policy things that
you believe in other candidate has done
wrong say Elizabeth Warren signed this
and Bernie was against it okay well that
that's information that's useful but in
reality just talk about why the person
you support is the best person and why I
should vote for them and there's you
know a lot of really
a Bernie bro was mean on Twitter stuff
floating around the internet that's not
what this is that is actually a
coordinated campaign to go after Bernie
supporters as a proxy to attacking
Bernie I'm talking merely about campaign
strategy and I think that attacking
other candidates at people's doors is
bad strategy it's likely that these
individuals were were a little over
exuberant and they went in a direction
that didn't make sense and in fact Pat
said a lot of what he was doing when he
canvassed for Bernie in New Hampshire
was ascertaining if the person planned
to vote for Bernie Sanders and saying
you know consider Bernie in a more
friendly way let me know what you think
of this let me know if anybody has
canvassed you and whether you
experienced something similar different
from Bernie Canvassers or other
Canvassers again I've only been
approached by Bloomberg supporters
Bloomberg campaign people and Bernie
campaign people at this point in time